[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and
welcome to episode
number 125 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform podcast.
I'm Mark Mandel.
And I'm here with my colleague,
as always, Melanie Warrick.
Melanie, how are
you doing today?
MELANIE WARRICK: Good.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm
doing all right.
MELANIE WARRICK: Good.
So who are we talking
to this week, Mark?
MARK MANDEL: We are talking to
one of our good friends, Sarah
Novotny, who is the head
of open source strategy
here at Google Cloud Platform.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
It was a fun conversation
talking about open source
and how we approach it
from Google's perspective.
So that was great.
And getting into CN--
MARK MANDEL: CNCF.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank you.
CNFC.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
And we're going to continue on
with cool things of the week,
and then finally have
question of the week.
I did something
stupid this week.
And then I fixed it.
MELANIE WARRICK: You did.
So we're going to talk about
how did Mark break the SSH
access to his Compute
Engine instance,
accidentally removing the
GCP Linux guest environment,
and how he fixed it.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
Because I'm silly.
MELANIE WARRICK: But
before that, as always,
one of the cool
things of the week
is that one of our
fellow developer
advocates,
[? Kasato, ?] he wrote
about how it's now live in Tokyo
that they are using TensorFlow
to predict taxi demand.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
This is really cool.
They have a live deep
learning model for TensorFlow
to predict how many
possible riders could
be waiting in a particular
block in the next 30 minutes.
And apparently it's like
93% to 95% accuracy,
which is kind of nuts.
MELANIE WARRICK: Right.
I know.
They said NTT DoCoMo collected
about 60 million subscribers'
location information.
And then they anonymised it.
And they've been using
that in conjunction
with a multi variable
auto regression model
and deep learning to help
build this model, in essence.
And so they've listed this
out in the actual post, how
they did this, what
services they used,
how they built the model.
And you should check it out.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
MELANIE WARRICK: All right.
Mark, anything from the
Kubernetes side of the world?
MARK MANDEL: There's always
stuff in the Kubernetes
side of the world.
Definitely want to
highlight the series
that Sandeep Dinesh,
one of our team members,
has been running with
Kubernetes' best practices.
He has a new post
out called Organizing
With Name Spaces and an
accompanying YouTube video,
basically talking about
what name spaces are,
how you could use
them, and why you
might want to use them inside
your Kubernetes clusters.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
It's a good series
that he's doing.
And name spacing is
always very valuable.
So you should also check
that blog post out as well.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
MELANIE WARRICK: Another
thing we wanted to mention
was that there is this new
contest, this image detection
contest that is
out there, and data
set that's been made available.
And Google Research, in
particular, is behind this.
They have a post out.
And we'll, of course,
include the link,
where they're announcing
what's known as Open Images v4.
It's containing 15
million bounding boxes
for 600 categories and
1.9 million images.
So this is the largest existing
data set with object location
annotations.
And there's more
variety in the category.
So there's an actual
contest behind this.
We'll include that link as well.
And they've got
the training set.
That's already available.
But the test set will be
available July 1 by Kaggle.
And the challenge is
unique because there's
about 12.2 million bounding box
annotations for 500 categories.
So check it out.
MARK MANDEL: Oh.
There's prize money.
The challenge has a total
price fund of USD $5,000.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
MARK MANDEL:
Sponsored by Google.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's right.
And apparently the results will
be determined by September.
So you've got a period
of time to play around
with the data set.
And/ or use it for any
additional research that
you're working on.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
Coming back to Kubernetes,
because what else do
I do with my time, there's a new
thing that came out recently,
[? Share ?] GCP.
So we're introducing the
Kubernetes Service Catalog
and Google Cloud Platform
Service [? to broker. ?]
The fancy title is Find and
Connect Services to Your Cloud
Native Apps.
This is kind of a little cute
and interesting project that's
part open source and part GCP.
Basically, it
makes things easier
for you to connect your
cloud native applications,
so your applications that run on
Kubernetes, to other services,
in this case particularly
GCP services.
So if you want to configure
like IM, and then be like,
hey, I want this to be able to
connect to Pub/Sub, or Cloud
SQL, or something like that,
this is just a really nice way
of being able to
have a UI interface,
and then being able
to be like, hey,
I need to install this thing.
And it sets all those
pieces up for you
so that you're ready to go.
So that's quite handy.
MELANIE WARRICK:
It is very handy.
MARK MANDEL: It's a
handy little thing.
MELANIE WARRICK:
We're actually going
to give one other cool
thing of the week,
a shout out to Julia Evans.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
MELANIE WARRICK: Who is
known as b0rk on Twitter.
She's done a number of zines.
And this one that
she's got out recently
is labeled "Bite Size Linux."
And she gets into how you
can think about Linux,
and what system calls, and
what files descriptor is.
I've seen her speak.
I've seen her content.
She's wonderful at helping
to break things down and make
them easy to consume.
So you should check those out.
We'll keep a link as
always in the show notes.
MARK MANDEL: I actually have
her Linux debugging tool zine.
It's attached to my wall next
to my computer at work here.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It's really good.
Awesome.
Well, why don't we go
have a chat with Sarah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Sounds good.
MARK MANDEL: I'm
particularly excited today.
This has been a long time
coming, and a lot of work
to make happen.
But I'm really, really happy
to have the very busy Sarah
Novotny joining us today.
How are you doing today, Sarah?
SARAH NOVOTNY: I'm doing well.
I'm actually
thrilled to be here.
And I'm very apologetic
that it took so long.
MARK MANDEL: That's OK.
We know you are a
very important person.
SARAH NOVOTNY: Yeah.
But busy is not supposed to
be a cultural norm for me.
MARK MANDEL: That's all right.
So Sarah is the head of open
source strategy at Google Cloud
Platform.
We want to talk to you today
about open source at Google
Cloud.
But before we do that, as
per usual, who are you?
What do you do?
What's your history
here at Google?
SARAH NOVOTNY:
And why am I here?
Existential questions.
MARK MANDEL: I can think
of so many reasons.
MELANIE WARRICK: 42.
SARAH NOVOTNY: Absolutely.
See, we're done.
So I am Sarah Novotny.
And as Mark said, I lead the
open source strategy group
for Google Cloud Platform.
And I arrived here at Google
via a fairly circuitous route
of systems administration,
database administration,
and a number of websites,
open source projects
that you've heard of.
So Amazon, NGINX, a video gaming
company you've never heard of,
but you may have heard
of the game, "Hawken."
And then, of course,
some time at [INAUDIBLE]
and running my own
business, working on MySQL.
So my first open source
project was really
MySQL, and my first love.
I did a podcast for more
than a year about MySQL.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
And I'm sure you could teach
us a few things in terms
of podcasts and what it was
like to be doing all that.
SARAH NOVOTNY: I think
you guys do a lovely job.
I don't know that I
can up the game here.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: Thank you so much.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know.
Thank you.
SARAH NOVOTNY: Flattery.
Flattery, yes.
MARK MANDEL: Indeed.
MELANIE WARRICK:
We'll take that.
MARK MANDEL: So yeah.
You're the head of open source
strategy at Google Cloud
Platform.
What does that mean?
What do you do with your time?
SARAH NOVOTNY: So let me tell
you a little bit about how
I got here inside
Google, because that
leads into the story of,
what does this group do?
Because this is a new group.
So I was hired into Google to
embed myself in the Kubernetes
community, and turn it from
being a company led project
to a community led project.
We knew that as the
player in cloud,
we needed to have a way to
change the portable workload
unit story for cloud.
It couldn't be VMs.
It couldn't be Java, JAR files.
We wanted to move this
along with the work
that we had done here at
Google with containers.
And containers have been the
backbone of Google's workloads
for 15 years.
And we did a lot of that work in
open source, in Linux early on,
and brought it out to the
world and made that possible.
But we needed to really
change the story,
because the story was very
much about VMs and cloud
at that point.
And so Google made this huge
investment in Kubernetes,
and built a team.
And the strategic goal was to
change how the industry talked
about portable workloads units.
And we needed to do that in
a way that allowed Kubernetes
to be ubiquitous.
That was the first
goal is we needed
Kubernetes to be everywhere.
We needed containers
to be everywhere.
And in order to do that, you
have to build a huge community.
And open source seemed a
really obvious way to do that.
It's a much easier way
than a single product,
because you get a lot
of people's input.
You get a lot of engagement.
You get other people advocating
for you and with you.
But you also can't then
have one company leading it.
So I was brought in to
help make that transition.
And then that turned
into sort of, oh,
and I'm doing an
open source project.
Can you help me
with my community?
And, oh, I'm doing an
open source project.
And then we open
sourced TensorFlow.
And we had different
strategic goals,
which then meant, how do we
deal with a community that
has different strategic goals?
And we've done open
source for years.
There's lots and lots
of open source work
that Google has done,
going back to the inception
of the company.
But it was usually, early
on, a scratch your own itch,
and then upstream it.
Make sure that we are
being good citizens, being
good open source citizens.
And then there was, of
course, Chrome and Android,
which were open source projects,
but they were very company led.
And the communities
were much more
about ecosystems, and
applications, and the adoption,
and ways to extend the
particular project.
But Kubernetes had
to be different.
And so we've seen all
these different strategies.
And now we're collecting a group
for Google Cloud Platform that
sits, embeds in communities
that are either first party
communities, communities
that Google has built
and wants to continue to grow,
or third party communities,
like Node.js.
I've recently joined the
Node.js foundation board
in order to help
that project become
more appealing to
enterprises, grow through sort
of the early adopter
phase, cross the chasm,
and get into the
enterprise adoption phase,
and grow as a project, make
themselves more long term
sustainable.
So my team covers a
whole pile of projects,
TensorFlow, Kubernetes, GRPC,
[? Isdio, ?] Apache Beam.
I know I'm forgetting something.
MARK MANDEL: Do
you do open census?
SARAH NOVOTNY:
Actually, we don't yet.
But we have consulted with them.
Which leads to the
next thing, because you
were going to ask me, what
does a day look like in this?
It's actually a lot
of meetings, sadly.
A lot of foundation meetings.
A lot of internal meetings,
finding new projects
that people are
building, and finding
what their strategic
goals are for them.
So trying to make
sure we understand,
or like you consulting me
about your gaming project.
MARK MANDEL: I was just
thinking about that.
SARAH NOVOTNY: Yeah.
That looked like that.
How do we achieve the goals
that we have for this project?
Is the project an interesting
way to showcase GCP?
OK.
That's one reason
we might have it.
Is it an interesting way
to get into a community
or an academic space,
and get to know
all the players in that space?
Are we trying to
recruit with it?
Are we trying to make talent
more portable as well?
Are we trying to make
workloads more portable?
So we look at what the
strategies are, and then we
try to build
communities that work
to engage with those
strategies, and deliver
good economic
benefit for Google.
Because while open source is
awesome and altruism is great,
we still are a business,
and I still pay rent.
So I would like to have
the business be successful.
MELANIE WARRICK:
When I was working
in open source, the
common question,
like everyone who would
meet me would be like, well,
how do you guys make money?
Not that that's
my question here.
SARAH NOVOTNY: I
was going to say,
I can answer that
for some of them.
MELANIE WARRICK: Actually, yeah.
Sure.
How do some of these
projects make money?
SARAH NOVOTNY: Well, the
interesting thing is, though,
when we talk to these projects,
and what their strategy
is and why, one of
the things we ask
is, and how are we going
to monetize this or not?
If we're not going
to, that's fine.
But we need to
know that upfront,
because then it's part
of the success criteria.
And for Kubernetes,
as an example,
we monetize it by having a
hosted version of the project.
We are one of many companies
that have a hosted version.
And that's fine.
But we differentiate
based on integrations
with our other products,
or our network,
or all of these different
things that Google
can bring to bear as a company.
For some of the other
open source projects,
there are parallel versions
that are products primarily.
Some of them also aren't yet.
And that's also great.
Some of them are just, we
were doing this anyway.
And we'd rather we had
an industry standard
and we led that
standard, as opposed
to being either locked in
by another person's standard
or locked out by their standard.
MARK MANDEL: That makes sense.
I can see certain net benefits
across certain open source
projects.
I think with something
like open census,
and the vision that
I've seen, or the vision
that I can see from [INAUDIBLE]
our podcast of being
able to have an integrated
toolchain that runs all
the way from GCP out into
the open source ecosystem
is very compelling.
So it makes sense for us
to work in that space.
SARAH NOVOTNY: Or
Forseti with security.
RSA is happening this week.
And the industry
needs these tools.
And we sort of have
been doing them anyway.
And it's not any
real secret sauce.
So why don't we share them and
help drive the conversation?
MARK MANDEL: Two
previous podcasts.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's
definitely smart.
Yes.
We'll have to link those.
SARAH NOVOTNY: Oh.
Were you talking Forseti
two previous podcasts ago?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
We had Forseti on
a little while ago.
SARAH NOVOTNY: Nice.
See.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well, and
also, prior to your podcast,
we had Eric Brewer.
And we talked about
his involvement
around getting
Kubernetes out there.
Did you guys work
together when you
came on and started leading up
the strategy around Kubernetes?
SARAH NOVOTNY: He actually
was even earlier than I was.
So I came in as we were
trying to make the shift
to move it to a foundation.
So I did a lot of the
early foundation work,
with Craig McLuckie.
But Joe Beta had already
moved out of Google.
He's still working
in Kubernetes.
but Craig McLuckie
was still here.
He's now since gone and
founded Heptio with Joe.
Brandon Burns was still here.
But Eric had been
sort of the strategy
at the very, very beginning,
and sort of the early documents,
and the early socializing of it.
But I wasn't interacting
with him a lot.
MELANIE WARRICK: Got it.
SARAH NOVOTNY: I have since
because we did a bunch of work
together last year
around Next actually.
MELANIE WARRICK: Ah.
Nice.
MARK MANDEL: So you
mentioned something
I think interesting
there when you talk
about the foundation, right?
SARAH NOVOTNY: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: CNCF.
What is CNCF?
What are its goals?
But also, what drives some
products to go to CNCF and some
don't?
And what's the impetus there?
SARAH NOVOTNY: Foundations 101.
So the Cloud Native
Compute Foundation
was created to house Kubernetes.
So the original
vision as Kubernetes
was being built inside
Google, even as we were just
having a couple of partners,
and just having trials with it,
and working out how we were
going to announce it, well
before I started, that would
have been late 2014, early
2015, there was a concept
that in order for this
to be much more trusted
by the industry,
it couldn't be just Google.
As I said, it had to be
really community led.
And Google has had
some challenges
with holding things too tightly.
And so we wanted to make
sure that it was clear
that Google was really
intentional about this.
And so in July of 2015 when 1.0
of Kubernetes was announced,
we announced, at the
same time, an intent
to build a foundation, and put
Kubernetes in the foundation.
We had looked at
other foundations
and talked about whether
or not they would fit.
But the Cloud Native
Compute Foundation
ended up being created.
And we wanted it to
be a broader story
than just Kubernetes,
because Kubernetes
was the start of
the transformation.
So the Cloud Native
Compute Foundation
looks at what it means
to build applications
that are built and architected
primarily for the cloud.
So the architecture that
it was framed around
was container packaged,
dynamically scheduled,
and something else really
important I'm sure.
[LAUGHTER]
Ha.
Microservices oriented.
There we go.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
Nice one.
SARAH NOVOTNY: I pulled it out.
MARK MANDEL: There we go.
SARAH NOVOTNY: So that
was the framing of what
it means to be cloud native.
And the cloud native compute
foundation is safe haven.
So it's not company led
for any of these projects.
The idea is it's
a great place that
is independent of any
particular company or company
agenda for multiple industry
partners and multiple industry
collaborators, and even
competitors to work together.
So there at this point I think
five of the top cloud companies
are all members of this,
and getting together
and working on this.
So how do projects get selected
or participate in the Cloud
Native Compute Foundation?
If your project is interesting
and relates to this cloud
nativeness there is a
technical oversight committee
that is independent of the
governing board and independent
of the corporate
contributions that
is setup to help guide
the projects that
participate in the Cloud
Native Compute Foundation.
So if you have a project,
and you want to participate,
you basically go to the TOC,
and make a presentation,
and say, here's why.
Here's what we would like to get
from the Cloud Native Compute
Foundation.
It might be marketing support.
It might be integration help.
It might be CICD help.
The Cloud Native
Compute Foundation
offers a lot of
services to the project.
And then so you say what you'd
like from the Cloud Native
Compute Foundation.
And you say, here's
where your project is,
and here's what the intent
is, and the goal, and here
are some users.
And there are different
levels at which
you can join or participate
in the Cloud Native Compute
Foundation when you
bring a project to it.
But the TOC has to agree.
MARK MANDEL: How do we
decide at a Google Cloud
level what goes to CNCF or not?
SARAH NOVOTNY: So
as it turns out,
that's a slightly
messy question.
MARK MANDEL: That's
why I asked it.
SARAH NOVOTNY: I know.
And there has been a new
policy created around this.
But generally, the idea
is we take a look at what
the goals are for the project.
And we see if that aligns with
it moving to a foundation.
So some of the projects,
[? Isdio, ?] as an example,
another open source
project here, we're working
on that with IBM very closely.
And we're working with the
intent to move it to the CNCF.
But it doesn't, at the
moment, have as many end users
as we would want to come
in as an incubated project
at the Cloud Native
Compute Foundation.
So we're growing that.
And we're working through
getting a solid governance
model down, and then potentially
moving it to the Cloud Native
Compute Foundation.
But it really is
alignment of goals,
and whether or not we want to
setup governance that would
meet the CNCF's requirements.
They're fairly limited, but.
MELANIE WARRICK: So I think
this is very interesting.
You've talked about
the independence.
How do you make sure
that it is independent,
that Google is involved, and
other cloud providers are
involved, and yet they are not
directing projects and having
influence over projects
that are trying
to come in that are not
from these organizations,
or even are from?
SARAH NOVOTNY: So, governance.
Governance is the
topic of the week.
So the Cloud Native
Compute Foundation
was actually built with
that model in mind.
So that's one of the
reasons we didn't
go to the Apache Foundation.
That's one of the reasons
we didn't go straight
to the Linux Foundation.
We wanted to build
our own little model
and our own little government
in order to make sure
that we had that balance.
And love him or not, Craig
McLuckie set this up.
And he built this
in a way that gives
sort of checks and
balances, much like the US
governmental system.
MELANIE WARRICK: Ah.
SARAH NOVOTNY: And so the
governing board is very much
a corporate membership board.
And it primarily
controls budget.
It controls some
of the marketing.
It controls how
people are engaging.
It runs the events.
But all of the
project interactions
end up happening with
governance pushed very much down
to the projects themselves.
And I started to say there's
very light requirements
around governance from the CNCF.
The requirements are it just has
to be really well documented.
And we really don't prefer
benevolent dictators.
It's just, we want
to see something
that's broader than that.
And we want to see a way
for a first time contributor
to be able to grow to
be a maintainer someday.
And so there's the governing
board, the technical oversight
committee, and an
end user board.
So these are the three branches
of Cloud Native Compute
Governance.
And the technical
oversight committee
has nine members
total, seven of whom
are appointed by the governing
board, who are not necessarily
supposed to be corporate
representatives,
but are industry
representatives.
So we have people that sit
on the technical oversight
board that don't have
governing board seats,
or their companies don't
have governing board seats,
because they are
representative of the industry
and the cloud native
view of the world.
Then there are two technical
oversight committee seats
that are selected by
the technical oversight
committee themselves.
They say, let's look at the
seven of us hanging out here.
And we say we're
missing this skill.
And we really need someone to
be able to talk about that.
So they select people
from the industry as well.
And that is the
group that ends up
having project level interest
for bringing projects in
or graduating projects.
Kubernetes was recently the
first graduated project.
So we're now an
official full project.
MARK MANDEL: Woo.
MELANIE WARRICK: Congrats.
SARAH NOVOTNY: Thank you.
Yeah.
That was back in March.
So the technical oversight
committee has that power.
They also have, I believe, in
their charter, a way to say,
if there's not a lot
of progress, I'm sorry.
You haven't graduated.
You haven't made enough
progress in some amount of time.
And so we need to move you on.
MARK MANDEL: Put you on a
personal improvement plan.
SARAH NOVOTNY: Right.
A Project Improvement Plan.
It's a PIP.
MARK MANDEL: There we go.
SARAH NOVOTNY: So
that's one group.
And then the end user
board also gets one member
that gets to be sat on the
technical oversight committee.
So there is also sort of a
perspective from an end user.
And so we tried to build
this balanced system.
It'll just be broken in
a new and different way,
because every system is.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
SARAH NOVOTNY: But we thought
this one through pretty far,
trying to make it more balanced.
MELANIE WARRICK: So
no gerrymandering.
SARAH NOVOTNY:
Here's hoping not.
MELANIE WARRICK:
So if somebody is
building out a project
and wants to open source and
look at submitting to CNCF,
what would be approaches
you'd recommend,
or resources you'd recommend
for them to consider?
SARAH NOVOTNY: Starting a
project is no small feat.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well, let's
say they've started one.
SARAH NOVOTNY: OK.
Phew.
[LAUGHTER]
MELANIE WARRICK: Let's say
they've already started it.
They've got something.
SARAH NOVOTNY: Right.
There are licenses.
There's a little
bit of governance.
We've got some code of conduct.
We're doing good things.
OK.
Yeah.
We maybe got some end users.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: Maybe.
SARAH NOVOTNY: Contributors
across different companies.
MARK MANDEL: Sure.
SARAH NOVOTNY: All right.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
SARAH NOVOTNY: Fantastic.
I just skipped all
the hard parts.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well, and
let's say they're independent,
and/ or their company.
Their company is
looking at doing this,
and they're trying to
figure out where to go.
SARAH NOVOTNY: I,
again, go back to what
is the strategic
goal of that project.
So if a company is trying to
make an open source project,
my suspicion is that
their strategic goal
is to get lots of
people excited about
and interested in the
project, and then they
have a way to monetize
it in some magical form.
And if that's the
case, then there's
a sort of rising tides lifts
all ships method in saying,
maybe Cloud Native
Compute Foundation, which
is really exciting, it
seems to fit with this.
Yeah.
We're totally down with
container packaged.
Oh, look microservices oriented.
All right.
Do we have dynamic scheduling?
Do we have good telemetry?
Can we play in this space?
Can we add value in this space?
And then if it fits with
those particular tenants,
and it seems to be a good
space and good technological
integration point with the
different other projects,
it's worth taking it to
the TOC and offering it.
But it really always goes back
to what is their goal for me.
Like if what they really want
to do is just be super exciting,
hey, get friends to
put it on Hacker News.
That'll get you further faster.
But if you want to be part of
a growing ecosystem in order
to draw in more
enterprise customers,
then Cloud Native
Compute Foundation
might be the right place.
If you want to show
up and have someone
say, here is
prescriptive governance,
and here's a whole bunch of
stuff that we can offer you,
Apache might be
the right choice.
There are lots and lots
of ways to do open source,
and open source within
foundations even.
MARK MANDEL: So now I'm
actually kind of curious.
What would be like, I don't
want to say the biggest
mistake, but maybe the biggest
mistake that you've seen,
or you can imagine that an
open source project could do
in this environment,
either to prevent them
from becoming largely adopted,
or access to contributors,
that kind of stuff?
What sort of challenges,
is maybe a better way
of putting it then.
SARAH NOVOTNY: There
are a couple right
now that are pretty common
and getting less acceptable,
which is not being
welcoming to people who
are new, not being inclusive.
Not allowing and accepting
that diverse voices,
even diverse skill set
voices can bring value
to your project.
20 years ago in
open source it was
perfectly OK to drum someone
out for asking a dumb question,
drum you off the
mailing list because you
asked something dumb.
Or answer RTFM.
And that's no longer
acceptable in any way.
And that will get you a
pretty bad rap in open source
right now.
Which is not to say there
aren't still projects
that run this way.
But they are known,
and they are not
what I would call the
forward motion way.
MARK MANDEL: So that is
actually interesting.
You say in 20 years
open source has changed.
I've got some opinions
on this, but I'd
love to hear yours on how
have you seen open source
change over the last 20 years?
It does seem like the landscape
has shifted quite a lot.
SARAH NOVOTNY: Well,
in 2010 we said
that open source had won, which
I thought was kind of awesome.
So I was also program chair
for OSCON for five years.
And so I did a lot of broad,
open source messaging,
and crossed paths with lots
and lots of projects that way.
And the tagline in, I think
it was the 2010 OSCON, was,
open source has won.
OK.
It's now the default
way to build languages.
way to build large scale
infrastructure projects.
You don't try to build
proprietary stacks so much
anymore.
The big shift that I saw,
which would have been right
around that time was
when MySQL, and Oracle,
and all of the proliferated
no SQL databases showed up.
They were all open
source, almost all.
Or OpenStack coming
in and saying,
no, we're doing open
source a new way.
We're doing it with
lots of companies.
We're doing it with lots of
big tent view of bringing
in lots and lots of projects.
We can argue all
week whether that
was a success or a failure.
But it was a new
way of doing it.
And it was a new default
where we saw people say,
we have a problem, and the
industry and the vendors
aren't solving it.
So we need to find a way
to fix this ourselves.
MARK MANDEL: It
also feels to me,
and I'd love to hear your
opinion on this, that
back 15 years ago, if there
was an open source project,
it was run by one person.
And everyone was
like, that's fine.
No problem.
Whereas now it seems like
an open source project,
if people come to it, if
it's not company backed,
or there's not a
large organization
of some kind behind it,
then it's not nearly as well
received I guess
would be the word.
Have you seen that sort
of happening as well,
or have opinions on that?
SARAH NOVOTNY: I have
lots of opinions on that.
I don't know that it's
not as well received.
But I think in the same way
that we have spent the last 10
years learning from
infrastructure having
single points of
failure, projects
having single points of
failure is a huge problem.
There was a great article, and
it's still probably a problem.
I'm not 100% sure.
The man who supports and
builds NTP is like one guy.
His source code is on his
desktop underneath his desk.
It's in an old
revision control system
that he's super familiar
with, but nobody else really
wants to get as involved with.
And so these are problems.
And we run our infrastructure
on this open source project.
So there was a lot of work
done over the last 10 years
to try to make those
projects more robust.
And it still is a huge problem.
We have libraries
that are completely
unmaintained in open source that
people use, and incorporate,
and include in everything.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
That's definitely a challenge.
What's interesting to me
from working in open source
is understanding the fact
that even though it's
company backed, doesn't
always necessarily mean it's
going to be as well-maintained.
SARAH NOVOTNY: No.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
I've seen both sides, from
individual parties to companies
being really great at it, as
well as also really challenged.
You've talked about
some of the challenges.
Where do you think open
source is going to go?
How do you think this is going
to look so many years down
the line from what
you're seeing right now?
SARAH NOVOTNY: I
think we're going
to continue to see large
scale corporate investment.
I think we will start to get
some more evolved templates
for new projects, evolved
templates for governance.
So it's not quite so much
making it up new every time.
As I said, there was
that big inflection point
from sort of
individual contributors
to corporate contributors
long about 2010 or '12.
We're still making
things up though, now,
even five years on.
And as I said, we make
new mistakes each time,
which is a great thing to
do, except for the fact
that it would be
great to just fix
some of the mistakes
in the other ones.
But 5 years, 10
years from now, I
think that we will see
open source be the way.
We develop a lot of the
shared infrastructure.
I think we're seeing
already that, as opposed
to the standards bodies
of the '80s and '90s,
we pull together around
an open source reference
implementation, and
then sort of write
a specification around that.
And then that becomes the
de facto industry standard.
The open container initiative
is a good example of this.
Docker did a thing.
It was based on containers.
This is super cool.
Containers had been
in Linux for years.
But Docker really did a great
job of making it accessible.
Then people got
worried that maybe they
had too much control.
But it was still open source.
So why don't we try to figure
out what the specification is,
and then make a reference
implementation that
is cross compatible with Docker,
and then compare that, and then
setup conformance tests,
and understand what
we mean by a container runtime.
What do we mean by a
container image specification?
Write all that out.
And this all happened
without a single standards
body being involved.
And so I think we're
going to see the standards
bodies continue to exist
and be used, because they're
super useful for especially
highly regulated industries.
But I think they will be a
second stop for open source
reference implementations
and specifications.
So I think that's going
to be one of the biggest
changes is that we do a lot
more in open source around that.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: And just to go
in a slightly different tack,
I've definitely run into
people, or corporations,
I should say possibly, who
when approached or discussing
the idea of open source, it
seems very foreign to them.
If you're a company,
and potentially you're
either looking at open
source, or even just wondering
why people would do
this, what do you
feel like the motivations
are for large companies
to really start going
down this trend?
And what are the
benefits, I guess, really,
at the end of the day?
SARAH NOVOTNY: There's a lot of
economic benefit to a platform.
And if you open
your platform, you
have more people able
to contribute to it,
which then gets you
a network effect.
So almost anything
that can be looked
at as a pluggable kernel,
for lack of a better term,
can benefit from being
open sourced and grown.
And then the ecosystem,
the addressable market
of whatever you're doing,
gets bigger because you
have a community around it.
And you have people that
are excited about it.
You have people advocating
for that platform,
advocating for
that new paradigm.
And then you have more
business opportunity.
So there's certainly
altruistic motives.
It's better for, many
eyes make shallow bugs.
There's lots of good reasons.
But ultimately, we
still live in a world
where this is commercial.
And in order to make
this viable for a company
to support, and
make it viable long
term sustainable, by
having multiple companies
and individuals come together
and build these sometimes
enormous projects, you need to
have business value come out
of it.
So there are good
economic reasons to do it.
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm curious.
What was one of your
favorite open source projects
when you first got
into the space?
SARAH NOVOTNY: So
I will always have
a soft spot for Red Hat Linux.
[LAUGHTER]
So I mentioned that I really
cut my teeth at Amazon back when
Web Scale didn't have a name.
And I started in
customer support,
because Amazon started
everybody in customer support
at that point in time.
And when I finally
worked my way through
and got to systems
engineering space, and got
moved over, just because I
knew the customer support
systems better than anybody
else in that organization,
so they brought me over as
like the local specialist.
And I could program
in Perl, which
really is a terrible thing
to say, but it's true.
MARK MANDEL: I've done it.
It's fine.
SARAH NOVOTNY: OK. (GROANING)
We won't talk about it.
So I was brought over
as this specialist.
And my boss walked by with
a stack of floppy disks.
Yes.
I'm dating myself.
Drops it on my
desk, and says, you
go on call when
your Linux desktop
connects to the network.
MARK MANDEL: Fun.
SARAH NOVOTNY: And that
was my first while.
I won't admit how long it took.
[LAUGHTER]
Because I was not at that
point a Linux administrator.
But very shortly thereon, I
was a Linux administrator.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
Very nice.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And look at you now.
So what do you enjoy
most about what you do?
SARAH NOVOTNY:
Helping people grow.
Helping projects grow.
Helping them understand how
to lead within projects,
and understand that open
source is really an opportunity
to take the skills you
have, offer them, and say,
I also want these skills.
I'm willing to do the grunt
work to learn them, and work
with people.
So I really see open
source as a great spot
to offer what you have
and learn new skills.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Anything that you
wanted to plug or share
that's upcoming for you?
SARAH NOVOTNY: So
there is a open source
panel happening at Google
I/O on Wednesday, May 9
in the afternoon.
And I'll be sitting on that.
Chris DiBona, our Open Source
Programs Office director,
will be leading the panel.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
SARAH NOVOTNY: And we
will have Will Norris, who
works in engineering
in Chris DiBona's team,
and then also
Cassandra Salisbury,
who is one of our go
people, works on my team,
and is embedded in the
Go community there.
She'll be participating
with it as well.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Well, thank you so
much for coming
on to the podcast
and sharing all
about open source.
And it was wonderful
to have you here.
SARAH NOVOTNY: It's lots of fun.
And thanks for putting
up with my reschedules.
MARK MANDEL: That's OK.
Anytime.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well,
thanks again, Sarah.
Hopefully one of
these days we'll
get you back, because
that was wonderful to get
into open source with you.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
MELANIE WARRICK: All right.
Mark, question of the week.
You broke your SSH access to
your compute engine instance
by accidentally removing the
GCP Linux guest environment.
[GLASS SMASHING]
[DIGITAL BLOOPS]
This reminds me of a time when
I think I did-- what was it?
Sudo--
MARK MANDEL: Like RMR?
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
So how did you fix this?
MARK MANDEL: OK.
So first of all, I want to
say, you should probably
automate all your build things.
Use containers, or some sort of
automation script, [INAUDIBLE]
So in this case I
wasn't doing this.
That's probably
mistake number one.
But I had a GC instance.
It's running WordPress on
it so I can run my blog.
And I was like, oh, a new
version of Debian's out.
I should upgrade
because security.
That's good.
So I sat down.
I went through the
steps, upgraded.
Everything was fine.
What I didn't realize was
in doing said upgrade,
there's a bunch of
GCP specific tooling
that handles all the SSH key
and security stuff for when
you want to SSH in.
So you can SSH in from
your browser, for example,
and/ or from the G Cloud
tools, and it handles all that.
Unfortunately, when I
upgraded, that thing goes away.
Unless you manually
take the step
to make sure that
tool is still there,
and the repo is still there,
and all that kind of stuff,
it just disappears.
So I was stuck with a machine
that I couldn't SSH into.
It was still working, but
I couldn't SSH into it.
Anyway.
So there's actually
a really good guide,
that we'll link to in the
show notes, that is actually
for if you're setting
up your own OS image,
or something like that.
But it is linked from
the troubleshooting guide
if you can't SSH in, talking
about how you can install
the tooling without
actually having
to be able to SSH into the box.
So they take you through steps
where you clone the disk,
fire up another VM,
mount and setup a setup
script that you can be
copy pasted into it,
fire up the thing.
And then basically
the machine loads up,
and then it installs the stuff
that it needs to install,
and it continues on from there.
And it works.
I can SSH back into my box.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Congratulations.
MARK MANDEL: So I will link it.
It's one of those
things that you probably
should never need
this, and hopefully you
will never need this.
But on the day that you
do, you will be like,
that's the thing I need.
OK, cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
Happens to the best of us.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well,
I'm glad you came out
of that sort of unscathed.
MARK MANDEL: Pretty much.
MELANIE WARRICK: And lessons
learned for everybody.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: All right.
Well, Mark, got any plans,
any place you're going to?
Any place you're speaking at?
MARK MANDEL: Outside of next,
which is in a little while,
just doing my live
streams on Twitch.
I did put out a
blog post recently.
I can mention
that, self-serving.
I'll put the link
in the show notes.
Basically I was
finishing off the series
I started a while ago,
talking about scaling game
servers on Kubernetes
in a manual sense.
So I finished off the
fourth one of that.
I will pretend it
wasn't meant to be five.
It was meant to be four.
That's the way it was meant.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Of course it was.
MARK MANDEL: Of course it was.
So I finished that off.
So yeah.
Just doing some streaming,
and writing some content,
and writing a bunch of
code for [INAUDIBLE]..
What are you up to?
Where are you going?
MELANIE WARRICK: I am
going to be speaking
at the Internet to Global
Summit, next week on May 9,
in San Diego.
And then I will be speaking
at the Understand Risk Forum
on May 17, in Mexico City.
That is where I will be.
Other than that, I
am in San Francisco.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
Well, it means we'll
see each other lots.
MELANIE WARRICK: Hopefully.
Unless I decide not to hang out.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: That's all right.
MELANIE WARRICK: All right.
MARK MANDEL: Well
Melanie, thank you again
for joining me for
yet another week
on this episode of the podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: And thank
you all for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[SINISTER LAUGHTER]
MELANIE WARRICK: All right.
MARK MANDEL: I just went very
Scooby Doo there for a minute.
I don't know.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know.
That was very Scooby Doo.
We should keep that for later.
[SINISTER LAUGHTER]